-Hey, guys. We live
in a brand-driven society.
[ Chuckles ]
-Nice segue.
-How's that for a segue?
Yeah. Yeah, how's that?
-That's great. I'm with you.
I'm still here.
-Y-Y-Y-Yeah.
Name recognition is everything.
The problem is what makes
a good name for one thing
might make a bad name
for something else
or a great name
for something else.
So with that in mind, it's time
for a segment we call
"Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."
-♪ "Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name," yes ♪
-First up,
we have "Don't Start Now."
That's a good name
for a Dua Lipa song.
It's a bad name for a racehorse.
[ Light laughter ]
A great name for
this year's flu season.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
Please, don't start now.
Please don't start.
After that, we have
"Little Fires Everywhere."
That's a good name
for a TV show...
a bad name
for a gender reveal party.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name
for Trump's PR team.
[ Laughter ]
Next up we have "Prego."
That's a good name
for a tomato sauce,
a bad name
for a birth control pill.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal clangs ]
It's a great name
for a drive-thru church.
[ Laughter ]
Pray-go. Pray-go.
-Aw, come on.
-♪ Hallelujah ♪
-That was the one.
That's all we want.
That was the one.
Up next we have
"Cheek to Cheek."
That's a good name
for a classic romantic song.
It's a bad name
for a Trump rally.
It's a great name
for seats on Spirit Airlines.
[ Laughter ]
And finally we have
"Oops!...I Did It Again."
That's a good name
for a pop song,
a bad name for Trump's
re-election slogan,
a great name
for an adult diaper.
That's all for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."